hong kong est une presqu'île située dans
le sud de la chine
plus de 7 millions de personnes y
habitent c'est une plaque tournante
majeure de l'économie asiatique et la
quatrième place boursière du monde
hong kong a été administrée par la
grande-bretagne pendant plus de cent
cinquante ans avant d'être rétrocédée à
la chine en 1997 le territoire
semi-autonome et gouverner selon le
principe d' un pays deux systèmes telle
qu'imaginée par l'ancien leader chinois
deng xiaoping hong kong a donc sa propre
monnaie
son propre passeport son propre système
judiciaire c'est la loi fondamentale de
hong kong qui lui sert en quelque sorte
de constitution
ce texte garantit pendant au moins 50
ans jusqu'en 2047 ou citoyens de wang
gang des libertés impensable pour les
chinois comme le droit de manifester et
exprimer ses idées
de même que la liberté de la presse
malgré ces garanties de nombreux
résidents de hong kong estime que pékin
s'attaque directement à leurs droits
depuis un certain temps
nous